voilà à l'âme alors vous vous êtes le
vainqueur il ya presque une analyse qui
reprennent des grands succès de la
chanson française sur cette compil
entrée d'artistes est le clip il est
raté son déconner c'est pas un clic
c'est un extrait de l'émission blanc
pascal quand je pense qu'on vous
reprochez de de faire chanter que des
vieillards finalement fait mentir la
légende c'est vrai ben vous voyez on
avait tort ouais j'ai toujours tout au
long de vue scientifique je fais plus
longtemps j'ai fait chanter toutes les
générations et est donc maintenant on y
refait j'ai fait chantre et aussi à son
idée je pensais que tu avais l'air
content qu est ce que tu as non mais
c'est à dire que je ne fais pas
tellement je suis venu en voisin
et comme tu m'as fait l'amitié de
m'inviter j'étais content de venir pour
alan c'est impressionnant pour lisser
première émission de télévision car quoi
qu'on dise je crois qu'à très long
tempérament chez ce garçon et donc je
suis venu parce que tu m'as faire
gentillesse de l'invité de m'inviter
sans ça je ne peux très peu d'émissions
de télévision comme tu le sais et je
n'ai pas du tout envie de venir faire
des gugusses rit donc je réponds aux
questions que tu me poses
mais s'il s'agit de faire le clown ça
n'est pas mon métier tiens et panneaux
relatant a compris oui alors arrête de
nous arrêter c'est pas non plus une
raison pour faire la gueule je veux dire
je ne fais pas la gueule je réponds été
question avec plaisir je suis content
d'être là j'écoute tes questions c'est
moi il s'agit par la gueule fini c'est
super si s'agit s'il s'agit de ce petit
jeu-là joe cole et parker je connaissais
depuis longtemps c'est la division
c'est bien ça s'amuse aussi mais quand
je suis chez moi je zappe un petit peu
mais ça me fatigue un peu
un don casier j'étais coûterait près ce
que tu veux ce qu en général question
sont pas forcément stupide bien
alors pascal j'allais écrire une chanson
pour le premier album un sourire ah ah
bon j'ai eu mon premier sourire mais je
la d'or ont plus rien les yeux qu'il
advient contourner ensemble qu'on boit
du vin blanc par la littérature et
politique
ce soit en et lui parlait un peu chanson
oui je ne vais pas d'exaspérer longtemps
pause mata question je réponds
maintenant pas d'accord alors la
question c'est pascal s'ils n'ont pas
une question vous allez écrire une
chanson pour le premier album de dahlan
ça fait longtemps vous n'avez pas écrit
de chansons voilà j'ai pas écrit de
chansons depuis très longtemps je ne
suis pas sûr que je vais en écrire
voilà donc peut-être faire une chanson
c'est pas l'objet je ne suis pas le
producteur de la tournée je suis pas le
producteur de disques ne s'est pas
l'auteur des chansons suis là je suis
l'homme qui fait de son mieux pour sur
les places publiques ouvrir une fenêtre
sur une génération
ils sont pas mal
alors
vous avez déclaré en parlant d' alan ils
brûlent d'un feu intérieur et ça se voit
quand il sourit oui bonjour chez vous
savez il y avait comme ça 7 500 audition
et puis un moment donné voilà on se dit
c'est lui ou c'est elle est évidemment
c'était lui voilà je suis pas absolument
abrutis quand je parle de chanteur ouais
aussi intéressant de bruno gaccio
quand ils parlent de liberté
d'expression est aussi drôle alors alan
ont parlé d' alan maintenant à l'âme
vous êtes originaire de la somme d'un
petit village qui s'appelle friville
escarbotin et maintenant tu es à paris
4126 habitants voilà vos parents michel
et michel possède une petite entreprise
de rondelle alors été tous les billets
voilà c'est regarder france et personne
nous dira explique vasile centre les
suivants fait avant la remontée des
rares cas pas le père chanteur ou la
mère chanteurs ou comédiens affaire qui
fait l'étude donc c'est bien pour lui et
des regrets encore trois serveurs il
fait des vannes tout le monde dit sourit
plus du junior famille quand même deux
musiciens votre père jules la guitare et
du trombone votre grand-père du
saxophone votre soeur du pipeau savoir
pareil que précédemment on les ponts
alors quand vous apprenez l'existence du
casting de pascal sevran vous hésitez
pas ce que voulait pas commencer par la
télévision pourquoi ce que gérant si
jamais couru les castings jamais été
très attiré par ça et j'ai tenté ma
chance par presque par hasard et je me
suis rendu compte après que c'était
vraiment une très bonne opportunité
soins chez pascal sevran ans le jour du
casting vous chantez amsterdam et ça
plaît pas parce qu'alain il est très sec
avec vous j'arrive et je lui demande de
chanter il m'a demandé ce que je vais
chanter ses dix amsterdam une influence
même chanson pour toi évidemment je
voyais ce petit garçon dire amsterdam je
trouve que c'est une chanson trop grande
pour lui j'ai voulu qui s'exprime
d'abord ce répertoire à lui on verra
après
j'espère il est évident que est évident
que ça me parait brel c'est très
difficile on peut pas comme ça voilà
donc je vais dit attends on verra plus
tard es tu as chanté quoi sans tache
tiend est quand même de patrick bruel je
remporterai chanter une mère de départ
pour mal réussi ni à partie bruel
d'ailleurs autant pascal avait été sec
au casting au temps après il a été
chaleureux
car nadal était très paternel il m'a dit
nous a beaucoup appris à tous à tous les
copains d'ailleurs des sondés sont là
derrière entre copains très amis et ses
rues de fil de vie nous n y vous
conseille ce qui n'est pas rien dit pour
relier méchant nord il a rien dit par le
colis les mettre en cause je remarque
ici ils se sont habillés comme il
voulait ils sont venus comme il avait
envie de venir enfin tout ça c'est on va
les voir
bonjour
nous souffrons
ce report a été fait elles sont quand
même farman et styliste très bien mais
tu deviens toi dont vous êtes la
nouvelle bande de pascal sevran
ouais vous aimez chanter quelque chose
là alors amsterdam
c'est tout à fait une chanson de groupe
une chanson green choix merci
il s'empare alain tu t'es fait plein de
nouveaux copains avec cette l'émission
finalement ils sont très bien
ouais ils sont réduits le dis pas ici tu
m' annoncé la mort de quelqu'un non
parce qu'on peut se mêle à bord de la
chanson déjà je prends très au sérieux
je veux dire ils ont comme ça une sont
ils font ça très bien c'est vraiment ils
sont ils sont très bien ils sont émus
ils sont contents et de ne pas envie de
faire de la plaisanterie là dessus voilà
grave c'est grave
sans déconner l'agenais les chanteurs de
la jeunesse et la passion la jeunesse et
la passion que matt ces jeunes gens à
leur métier c'est on était très
important donc je suis content de voir
les parrainer chez chez thierry ce soir
alors alan pascal ne s'est pas contenté
de lui donner votre chance il vous donne
aussi des conseils alors justement on va
tous en profiter parce qu'elle quels
conseils donneriez-vous à un jeune
chanteur qui débute d'abord une
détermination formidable terreau l'idée
qu'on veut faire ça et rien d'autre
deuxième chose ne surtout pas s'occuper
d'être à la mode parce que là c'est raté
convaincant puisque à peu près dans
toute l'histoire de la chanson française
ils sont à l'abri de ça va tenir ma
phrase parce que sans ça je finis ma
phrase il s'agit des jeunes gens moi
j'en ai rien à faire je le deviens
partir le gugusse ici je finis ma phrase
et je hais je vous dis que il n'y a pas
d'exemple quasiment de vedette de music
hall de la chanson française qui ont qui
sont arrivés en semoule en se couchant
dans la mode voilà alors posé une
question j'essaie de vous répondre le
plus possible donc l'idée simplement ne
pas se gavent aller courir par savoir
dans la mode parce que le temps de la
rattraper
elle est déjà passé d'accord quels
conseils donneriez-vous un vieux
chanteur qui débute encore d'être en
bonne santé chantier toujours temps
parce que il faut et il faut pas
employer ces jeunes ces adjectifs qui
rit vieux vous allez être bientôt que je
pense qu'ils n'ont pas bien quels
conseils donneriez-vous à pascal sevran
jeune je donnerai un conseiller pascal
sevran
à cette heure ci doit être couché
bonsoir
voilà
ouais c'est ça les rend bien
jme affaire parce qu'elle se rend mon
pote jean reno premier alors savoir
chanter mes parents quels conseils
donneriez-vous à pascal sevran jeunes de
continuer à faire ce qu'il a fait parce
que mine de rien il a servi la chanson
française une certaine façon chanson
française que je n'achète pas et que je
n'achèterai sans doute jamais mais au
moins il a servi à ça à la télévision et
continue un quart d'heure s'il est ravi
et méchant transforme secondes ban
quels conseils donneriez-vous un
chanteur qui ne veut pas de conseils de
pascal sevran
ben écoute parce qu'elles souffrent
c'est pas des conseils bien est-ce que
la lame que les biens la chanson
française vous croyez pas ici cogné
amsterdam de brel il connaît la chanson
française vient jamais toi là tu fais à
la nallet et jouissif pour bâcher les
toitures et son grand roman et la cité
compte sur moi pour faire sur bafici à
la place de sevran sinon moi pour moi
c'est alors tu veux un collier ahmed
bien est-ce que alan que mébiame et
chanson française
alan connaîtra demain la chanson
française est-ce que alan c'est que
charles trenet nous a quittés à l'âge ne
sait pas que charles trenet nous a
quittés il faut pas lui dire parce
qu'elle année sensible
si ribéry est ce que alors on en perd un
petit jeu alan je vais vous dire des
gens comme vous allez me dire mort ou
pas mort d'accord aller allons-y
reggiani morts fort heureusement
mouloudji morts richard anthony vivant
nino ferrer mort bien l'âme bien il
connaît bien la chanson georges moustaki
vivant vivent très bien
alan est ce que pascal vous a déjà dit
tu sais tu as un truc bruel n'avait pas
à ses débuts
enfin c'est que j'ai d'avoir un copain
confiant déguste beaucoup de pascal du
livre
je bats ta gueule
ça va aller et moi ton beau sourire
parce que je suis venu ici pour répondre
à des questions je parle de musique ok
donc je répondrai à vos questions
monsieur ardisson j'irai jusqu'au est ce
que pascal vous a déjà dit sur ton album
je prends 80 et wav un jeu il m'a dit on
prend je prends 80 et tu prendras et
j'ai dû utiliser question me dsk face à
caen samedi
ces questions sont très très dérangeant
raison qui est simple c'est que je ne
suis pas le producteur je ne suis pas
l'autre je sais mieux tu mets tes mains
comme mitterrand c'est marrant et c'est
un hommage c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais
beaucoup il ya des références beaucoup
plus désagréable impression d'avoir déjà
vécu cette scène c'est marrant moi aussi
alors est ce que parce qu'elles seront
vous a déjà dit attends tu vas passer à
la télé habillée comme ça quand même
oui mais je lui ai dit tu peux faire
tout ce que tu veux mais je garde le
collier est ce que pascal seulement vous
a déjà dit tu vas voir dix ans un gros
con au fond il est sympa comme il ya des
mots il ya des moments où il faut
essayer de raison garder au maximum de
faire ce pour quoi nous
alors maintenant vous verrez vous verrez
alan pascal sevran est un magicien